un décor de choix pour cette exposition
d'oeuvres monumentales dans la tour des
minimes du château d'amboise les
personnages qui ont façonné la légende
du lieu sa fiche grand françois 1er
diane de poitiers catherine de médicis
ils ont tous eu droit à se faire tirer
le portrait par charlotte de maupéou
faire regarder beaucoup d'image j'ai
beaucoup dessiner j'ai regardé la
peinture de la renaissance qui était pas
une peinture que je connaissais très
bien pour essayer de la manger de me
l'approprier comme un ogre donc j'ai dû
faire deux cents dessins et puis de ses
200 dessins ça a été créé mais et puis
j'ai gardé ce qui me paraissait voilà
les plus excitants pour les
et réinvestir de façon moderne les
retravailler les remontrer et essayer de
m'amuser
reprendre l'iconographie renaissance
c'est jouer avec les symboles chacun son
totem diane de poitiers en deviennent
chasseresse à l'antique catherine de
médicis très cavalière où françois 1er
jamais sans ses épaulettes
je me suis trouvé un peu trop
respectueuse avec ce françois 1er et du
coup je me suis mais qui est françois
1er et c'est un chasseur donc j'ai
essayé de voilà il ya cette espèce de
tir comme ça ces tâches qui passent sur
lui et puis on sait pas bien s'il fait
ce qu'il est en train d'étrangler
et bien sûr léonard de vinci léonard de
vinci est mort dans le château d'amboise
et donc je voulais y faire référence et
pour moi c'est vraiment tableaux
importants avec la douceur de cette
jeune fille à l'hermine
voilà avec ce personnage qu'elle tient
dans les bras ce côté très raffiné
une exposition à découvrir à la fin du
parcours de visite du monument jusqu'au
6 septembre
[Musique]